i have died my share of knight of deaths
yeah me too neither of us complicated
and
in fact we're going to start taking a
look at some of the games because there
are so many and i think you know
uh we're gonna take a look at some but
you can also
look on your own um for a night of games
that happen either in this tournament or
like
this year in top level um
so we can we can go ahead and take a
look
and of course natural knight of moves
in case you don't play the neither um oh
and you want to get into it
you have to understand that in this
position right after a6 and it becomes
an either
there are so many options like this is
an option bishop e3
bishop d5 is the main line bishop c4
there is f3
there is a4 which we're going to take a
look at there is h3 and
h4 i believe um there's knight b3 also
there's bishop
two there are so many moves there's
bishop c4 i think i mentioned already
but that's uh
that's a saucing variation favorite of
bobby fisher
so there are just a ton of ton of lines
and it's
it's probably what's so difficult to
grasp about it
um but it you know knowing general ideas
is always
it's always good yeah rg1 also is a move
yeah yeah um even f4 i think is a move
um f4 i think you go e5 and out of three
knight d7
um when you make
always the most popular moves for both
sides starting with e4
then you'll get the naidr wouldn't that
be like a real opus
or like an italian i just feel like e5
is a lot more popular than
than than sicilian i may be wrong though
but i had that feeling yeah yeah there
are a bunch of moves in this position
maybe three is a move yeah knight b3 is
a move and it's really tricky actually
so yeah there are a lot of a lot of
lines here
in fact i think someone played
was it knight b3 or a4 someone played
i think someone played knight b3 against
me
not just someone uh polina chuvalova
from russia um she's like 24.50 i want
to assume
feed um and she's really strong and she
the year that we played uh she became
a world youth girls under 18 champion
and world junior champion so
she was having a good run and i survived
with the draw that's all i can say
but yeah
yeah for example we're gonna take a look
at a4 because that's one of the
one of the lines that came up the knight
b3 now that we're mentioning it
and like i said i feel like today's
lecture is going to be a little bit
different it's going to be more of a
debate discussion on the neither rather
than you know
me explaining everything um
but knight b3 is interesting because you
know it kind of moves another way
because
before this tempo happens so oftentimes
if they play with epoch you can play for
the d5 square in fact i think it's
something like this
um what did i play
i think i played bishop e7
in my game but i can't
i can't say for sure actually no i think
i played something like this
did i no i don't know it's been a long
time
but yeah it's it's kind of tricky
because when they play five you can go
here and i guess it's kind of a little
bit similar to those
what is the name to those um spashnikov
perhaps you know like when uh they play
with e5 like you kind of tempt them to
play e5
and then you put the bishop on g5 and
you play for the d5 square
it does happen a lot in the sicilians in
general but
um yeah so that's that's the thing
square on the e5 tends to be very
important like the
the square on d5 and the pawn on d6
those are really important things in the
in the neighborhood that you'll always
kind of have to keep a look and look out
for the pawn on d6 can be weak sometimes
and it is really nice if black actually
manages to break with d5
and it is a good move um so
yeah you know those are some things too
to keep in mind
so yeah and it does take everything here
takes years of experience don't think it
doesn't i have played the neither for
like nine years
it's not like i can it's not like i
dominated you know it's
it's not like i understand everything in
it
i i do know some but
um nowhere knowing everything
so but actually um a5
is one of the sorry a4 is one of the
things that were
was playing this um in these games
and a4 is kind of interesting because as
you can see
it kind of stops the general neither of
you know queen side idea of the pawn on
the a6 and opponent b5
sometimes pushing for b4 and this is
this is usually nice for black because
not only do you gain space on the queen
side
and it is useful in case you know uh
white plays some sort of like
english attack where they cast along but
also because often times the bishop can
come to
b7 and with b4 ideas of b4
you can put a lot of pressure on e4 so
a4 stops those ideas
and just looks to gain space on the
queen side and perhaps play a bit more
solidly
it's not out of a4 you're probably not
going to see an either
for both sides are castled in opposite
direction they're just throwing pieces
at each other you know what i mean
so it's it's it's something to to
mention
um here of course you can play with e6
very natural
um something like bishop e2 bishop b7
castle castle
i would say that a4 often times
transposes to like bishop e2 neither
which is
uh perhaps one of if not the most solid
line
so um that's one thing to know we're
going to briefly talk about it
later because that's the variation that
mvl played with the white pieces
more than one time in this magnus
carlsen invitational
so yeah but it does transpose like this
type of variations
you know uh with queen c7 for example
and usually you know since um
it's very interesting something that i
discovered in this line
so usually white plays for b sorry black
plays for b5
right they play for b5
and of course in this case that's not
that's not possible so you may be
wondering well what happens with this
bishop
so this is all the main line moves king
h1
bishop no not bishop d7
um wait where am i in the variations
oh takes yeah takes and queen takes and
now bishop d7
and this is one way to play and
for example if like a5 bishop c6
and you're solid and also
if i wanted to show something
um
i guess it's not
here maybe it was in the north line but
there was something interesting
that i was looking into
huh where did it go
maybe it has maybe i'm just confusing
the variations as you usually would
in this lines but i was looking into
a line where um
where you can kind of do
a little bit of a different setup but i
guess this is also possible i think
there are also some ideas of coming with
the rook too
uh either d8 or rook to e8 and then
bishop to f8
and that's another possibility um
but yeah essentially this bishop can
come to d7 and c6 and try to put some
pressure here
since you know the diagonal is still
weak for not weak particularly but it's
kind of like x-raying the the white king
and um you can't really
play with b5 because of takes and b6
sometimes weakens too much
so that's that's one thing
i've never lost a game in the sicilian
night of
i'm guessing that's because you haven't
played it so yeah
neither was my very first opening that's
crazy i
well i have mentioned it before but um
when i was a kid
after one year of playing chess i'm
still a kid
but when i was younger um so
when i was younger um after one year of
playing chess
i told my coach hey i don't want e5
um i don't want to play kids openings i
want to play something exciting i'm
gonna play the sicilian
and he was like are you sure i was like
yes and then he showed me a few
different lines
and neither have had the coolest name so
i went for that one and
um i of course is another mess i got
myself into
also i am back now to playing e5 and
like that's also one of like the
top lines for the top players so it's
not really kids openings
but um essentially the funny thing about
it is that i didn't know the mess i was
getting myself into
when i was like eight so um
that's pretty cool uh all right so
but yeah so that's one way of playing
but in the game they continued with e5
and so we kind of briefly mentioned
before
right how um after you play with the e5
you have to be careful because the main
thing is the square on d5 and whoever
gets to control
the square on d5 better usually ends up
with an edge in the position right
knight one to f3 pawn to h6
this is very common because of bishop e6
uh there's one move we want to avoid as
as black
do you guys have any idea
wait i don't get that i don't want to
play kids openings talia
oh and then aronian says nothing oh yeah
he does play e5
quite a bit i think he played it a lot
in this tournament
um sorry
but do you guys know why why you play h6
and not bishop e6
should be very simple you know it's kind
of being implied
yeah knight g5 so after bishop e6 oop
valero after bishop v6 you don't want to
alana g5 because it just forces the
bishop to go back or do something
different so it's it's just
uncomfortable
so h6 is actually very common
um h6 is common and for example g3 this
is what happened in the game
if bishop to c4 you can actually play
bishop to e6 because
it's different you're trading for a
bishop you're not trading for a knight
so after it takes
um white is going to have a hard time
you know trying to make use of the
light squares because they also don't
have a light supervision and
this also opens the f file for black so
when they castle
they can probably use the f file and
they have more support in the center
the e5 is covered right they don't have
to worry about this anymore
so that's why they can't afford to play
bishop e6 if the bishop goes to c4
but in this game g3 was played i believe
this is carlson with the white pieces
against nymphomianchi
i kind of pasted in a ton of games
um and then i got
a little confused with the titles but
i'm pretty sure that this is carlos and
against nepal nietzsche
and um yes after
after g3 bishop to e7 was played
bishop d2 castle castle everything makes
sense
bishop e6 and um knight to h4
knight to h4 was played and this is a
very interesting idea and if you think
about it it makes a lot of sense because
you kind of want to you know
have ideas of controlling uh
the squares that your most advanced one
i guess you could argue that a4 is also
the most advanced one
but not really um so you can you kind of
want to
look after the square so your most
advanced one is controlling like
of course d5 and f5 and it kind of makes
sense you want to bring the knight here
first of all because it wasn't doing
anything on f3
second of all because if they take take
you know your bishop is going to have a
beautiful diagonal
and also because it may allow you know
the
f pawn to move forward so i think that
that's a very interesting move
if i'm not wrong it's a novelty so
h6 and a6 looks like a kids game
well they have a purpose okay
um instead of h6
if bishop e6 is bishop d5 good
um bishop d5 is fine but knight g5 would
be a bit better because you're
putting troubles on the on the
on the e6 bishop but it is good it is
fine
there are in fact a lot of ideas of time
um we're going to talk about them
you know a little bit forward but there
are many ideas of playing bishop g5 and
bishop takes f6
in variations where the pawn are on d6
and e5 because the knight on f6
is one of the main defenders of d5 and
as i was mentioning the d5 square is
very crucial
uh white then can proceed to do stuff
like c4 b3
queen b3 rook d1 um they can't even try
to bring the other knight to like f1
e3 and support the knight on f5 sorry on
d5 i have seen a lot of this type of
things and it's very difficult to play
as black with so little space
so bishop d5 definitely you know
it's one of the options in this pawn
structure of course right now there's h6
so you can't really do that but it is
one idea to give up the bishop for the
knight on f6
so after knight to h4 which
we mentioned inter symbol um
here uh napoleon she probably should
have played with something like bishop
to g4
and let's say queen d3 because it looks
natural
knight f6 developing h3 bishop black
rook d1 and something like queen c8
putting trouble
on this one since you provoked it to
move and
getting the queen out of the way maybe
this rook is coming to d8
and essentially position is fine for
for for black right
but instead he went knight to d7
and it's kind of interesting how the
position is going to start shifting now
um g5
i think g5 is a little too much um
i think g5 you may be helping the ideas
of f4 that they have
plus they probably would go in that f5
anyways
um it just feels like you're weakening
your king sign
i don't know if i appreciate that
so yeah but 97
was played and the thing is that now
after 925 take stakes
um now as we mentioned before like this
bishop has a really nice diagonal
there is still a lot of control on d5
three pieces looking at it
um and white now has a pair of bishops
and
black doesn't so you'll see how it
just turned to be very very comfortable
for
for white
now that i said very very it reminds me
of
everyone in the in the youtube chat
for chess 24 is commenting how
um peter leko says very very natural or
like very very bad very very good
um you know for like describing moves so
that's funny
um yeah
how about something like knight c6 to d4
to prevent those
knight f5 ideas i feel like oftentimes
you can try to do that but you can be
faced with something like
knight to e2 um and c3 or knight to d5
and c3 so let's say
well i think right now you're not on
time to do so
but let's say i don't know let's say you
went here
right and then the knight went to h4 and
then you go
here i don't know though because
i don't know to me just kind of feels
like it's going to be
a bit tough maybe maybe it is possible
um i think it may be something like when
d3 to then do this and this
all right like bishop b392 so like if
here here
perhaps it can be interesting but
um i am not sure i mean oftentimes
it's kind of hard to do but if the
knight goes to c6 i don't particularly
have to go knight to h4
i'm guessing i can do something else
like
i don't know let's say bishop e3 that
looks okay
preventing this um
that could be a move of night here i
assume
maybe this
and then you have the control of d5
probably
i assume that this is fine like
something like 23
c3 and then bring rooks over to attack
this now metaphor
sorry knight c4 knight d6 perhaps so
yeah
lego often got freaked by
young's moves today um
yeah um i mean he did play i believe he
played very aggressively today i mean in
general he's an aggressive player but
i think i stopped at one point and lekka
was saying something like
i don't think i could ever play like him
or something this is more
perfectionist than technical so
that's that's something you mentioned i
believe
bishop d3 sends the knight back or upon
is going to be lost
i imagine you you're saying bishop e3
but
yeah that's that's also interesting
so like here perhaps
could be a move i mean there is this so
i'm not sure but
don't be messy
but yeah however uh i believe those
options would have been better anyways
than knight to d7
because asian eyes are after knight to
f5 to x6 you're not really going to have
any sorts of counterplay for
um what you have lost positionally
so after queen c7 a5 controlling space
and fixing the opponent b7
rook to b8 bishop to e3 not really
giving way too many chances for this
phone to
do anything go anywhere
so group c8
going to d6 uh sorry queen to d3
bishop to f8
now rookie of c1 and i feel like the
move that is about to come
is very familiar i guess i should say
because if you you're looking at this
from the white side
right let's look at it from the black
side real quick
how do you continue like how do you make
moves because it's not simple
it's not simple to know what to do like
for example knight to c5
uh knight to c5 there's just queenie two
like they are not going to take
and give away their bishop or trade some
extra pieces
they're going to keep the tension in the
board and
they kind of just control a lot more
squares than black do so it's gonna be
really difficult to
to make moves and already right here
it's not easy what to do because this is
so well covered d5 is so well covered
and you're lacking the lights for bishop
to you know fight against it so
um it can be really uncomfortable
g4 h4g5 ideas
um i guess those
can be possible i don't know it depends
i think it makes more sense to play with
h3 and g4 which is similar to
what happened in the game because at
least for now i think they can kind of
play with queen c4
and they can put a stop to like animate
that you are planning to do so also you
need to
cover g4 when you do this so that's
gonna take some extra tempo
and probably queen c4 can get rid of the
queens
so yeah but what i wanted to say is that
this is very familiar because then uh
black
kind of played b6 and this is uh
more desperate than we have hoped to be
it's more of a
weakening trying to get something back
or something out of it but it's just
really weakening for
for black and this is a really big
mistake
not only that but i guess you're kind of
opening the position slightly more
and we have the bishop pairs and the
rook on the a file ready to you know put
pressure on the pawn on a6 so it just
kind of gives
and just kind of gives chances to
through white uh more than just you know
a space advantage so after it takes
takes root 2 a 6
knight to c4 happened knight to d5
and real quick if knight takes bishop
takes
and it takes takes
white is doing crazy good especially
because this is not an option
why is this not an option
yeah there is always ampersand so even
if you play b5
uh white is going to take it funny
enough so yeah
i guess rook c6 is one good move but
rook a7 is just so much better
because you're attacking the phone on f7
with the bishop and with the rock
and of course this is not possible
blocking is not possible because we can
just take it
and the rook is also supported by this
queen right here so
um it's kind of like everything works on
on white's favor
and if you take a look at this you could
argue that it can be drawish because
it's bishop of opposite color
but this is still you know there are
still other pieces in the board like the
queens and the rooks and
the position is very dangerous because
of that and
right now um white
uh is not only a pawn up but they also
um they also have the initiative the
open file
and with spawn with pawn on f7 that
black is going to have to take care of
and in general
you know when there are still similar
pieces on the board
uh opposite color bishop is not just a
draw because you look for initiative
and you'll probably find it so just
saying
so root takes v2 b7 yeah we talked about
that
so going to the a this is what young
play
and after b3 kicking that away takes
queen takes rook c5 c4
everything solid queen c8 knight takes
pawn takes rook to a7
queen takes f5 bishop d5 remember this
is a
rapid game so it's tough to to play
but you know after this queen g5
um they could have just played rook b1
but in the game um sorry
in the game they went
where did they go oh yeah no in the game
they went here would be one
and after takes takes rook b4
bishop takes f7 king h8 bishop d5
back rook to c8 king to g2
rook f7 and the last move of the game
yes gary won today so he he became the
champion of the tournament
so what do you guys think was the last
move with this game
which i guess kind of makes sense based
on stuff that we have previously talked
in this class and
i don't know just general sense of
disposition
oh you guys recommend polite
yeah rook 2a1 rook 2a1 and of course it
makes sense that one piece that is not
doing anything just bring it into the
game
gonna get into a7 and how do you defend
everything there is just no way
so after this move napoleon cherry sign
and
um you know it's it's understandable and
overall i feel like it was a very um
correct game by carlson overall and i
would say that the two biggest
things in black's play where this knight
d7 here along knight f5
and also b6 here which you know opens up
the position a bit more
true but it is all in white's favor so
overall it just seemed like carlson was
on top of this game the whole time
and he was the one putting pressure on
black
so yeah now you know that even a4 is
interesting because why not
right um yeah so it was it was a very
interesting game
and um there are actually some other
variations that i wanted to
take a look at um which is
which are very interesting they were all
played um
in this event and bishop e2 is a line
that
maxine played a lot i don't know if a
lot but he played
with the white pieces um
in this tournament against giri so it's
really funny because at least him
i think colors were doing too uh gary
was
going into the sicilian with the black
pieces
uh and then when he was white pieces
everyone kind of uh sorry the neither i
meant the knight if gary was going to
neither with the black pieces and when
giro was white pieces
everyone like slightly avoided the night
of so i don't know
i don't know if it's just that he knows
it really well and
the other players can sense it or maybe
they just like all planned to not play
the ground floor
uh sorry then either why do why did i
say grandfather that's
another one of my favorite lines so
yeah hi coogly how are you
let me give you your usual shout out
um everyone go follow my
friend hubli really cool guy good games
uh wholesome chat awesome people
awesome conversation so go check him out
get him to 100 followers all right
so back to chess so yeah i was
mentioning
that i saw that everyone was kind of
avoiding the neither when gary was on
the white side
and um nvl one of the things he did us
white was bishop to e2
and bishop tv2 is like i said
earlier perhaps the most solid line in
the
in the neighborhood uh you know
it's solid because you oftentimes see
short castle and you see shark castle
for both sides and you're playing kind
of more technical in the center not
really
like going after checkmate um you never
know of course you can't be too
you can't be too naive but
uh for the most part that's kind of how
it goes
and e5 knight to b3 happened
bishop to e7 one quick thing though that
i want to mention
bishop to e7 you kind of want to lay
bishop to e6
uh because in the opponent may have a
four right away
but you play bishop to e7 first usually
and if they play bishop to e3 do not
castle
move orders too important play bishop e6
already since they already developed
this bishop when they play f4 takes
they're going to expend an extra tempo
so you're not really worried about
moving your bishop to e6 already because
of f4 because you know they're going to
expand the next episode too
so just my great advice to you is don't
castle right now
because then not g3 but g4 and you're
going to suffer a lot i can tell from
experience
um uh so yeah just be really careful
with that
um i had this game a couple years ago
where i was just lost and i was
trying to survive and hold on and i did
i
pulled like a miracle or something but
it's it's really
um not a great idea and i played castle
without thinking much because i didn't
really know this trick
so um just just know that it's
it's very annoying to play against so
yeah
if you're black pieces just don't castle
play bishop e6 here
don't cast it until day castle how about
that once white castles then you can
castle as black
so yeah
um hello sega my sister
is playing the flute i don't think you
can hear it but she's playing the
flute right now what a great time
um what a great time
um delayed keras attack kind of yeah the
thing is that
you know their king is relatively safe
on e1 like it there's no clear way to
attack it
and then they're just going to start
pushing you know pawns on the kingside
and that's very scary so
that's my one piece of advice to you but
after bishop to e7
and vl castle castle and he had two
two ways of playing here but i thought
23 was probably the most interesting one
and 23 kind of is going to play with the
ideas that we mention of playing for the
d5 square so i'm most likely going to
bring the rook to d1
and they're going to put pressure on the
on the pawn whether it is with bishop to
g5
or um just something else
but it's it's a common move and after
bishop to e6
bishop to d2 was played rook to e8
knight to d5 and now takes takes
and bishop c1
ah yes so here it is what i thought it
was um
kind of interesting the way that the way
that they play
and as you can see you traded the
knights you could have traded the bishop
uh it's a thing that happens sometimes
and then you do something like this to
try and
to try and get the the phone back but in
this case
black didn't want to give the the bishop
up so they decided to take with knight
and paul takes and then bishop to see it
and you may be wondering okay what is
the future of this bishop now it has
nothing to do
uh you'll just see
so after
uh a4 decided they did not want to allow
a5
to control this square you know to have
ideas of this
to uh you know perhaps some ideas of
that or have some ideas of this
so i decided to play a5
and after f4 because let's say if you
don't
play a 4 you play like 23 or something
what do you think is the main idea from
black when playing a5
anyone has any clues
looks like an outpost for the knights
human b5
i guess you're right but also how's the
knight getting to b5
knight b4 eventually um
i guess so i mean they can always play
c3 though
so i don't really know about that
b6 bishop e7 that's kind of close
they want to play b6 bishop a6
and um eventually you know if they trade
you can put an item c5 later so that's
the idea the bishop no longer had a good
square on e6 it went back to c8 and now
we're trying to find like a better
you know outcome for it so this is a
very interesting idea
like for example b6 now uh f4 bishop a6
and the position is fine for black and
eventually of course if they
if they take for example knight takes
and you can't really take pagan queen
takes because of this
um but you then this is actually not
helpful because it opens up the
the bishop from black but eventually
this knight can come to c5
and the whole structure is rather solid
so but
it's kind of just doing something with
the piece that stop doing anything at
all so yeah
yeah it is a cool idea so
after f4 was played because you know um
this is the game right
sorry this is very confusing with like
the thousand variations that
kind of appear on the chest when you
have way too many
sub variations so but yeah this is what
happened in the game and then after f4
bishop to a6 takes takes uh
takes takes
you know just know what happened this is
the line that i was playing
it's confusing f4 right away happened
that's what happened i wish you could
see
like how many lines i have on the side
um
that are just way too way too many kind
of takes like half of the annotation
board
but that's fine that's fine
um but yeah so f4 right away was played
now knight to d7 uh you know hoping out
so that it takes knight takes
and queen to e3 was played
and now takes
queen takes knight to e5 controlling
squares bishop to
b5 bring a root to c8
ah i think there was something i wanted
to mention here
yes so i was wanting to mention
that yeah i wanted to mention something
after takes takes 95 bishop b5 for good
fate
you essentially kind of give some
temples to white now it's their turn and
they can play something like
well they played rookie one in the game
but they can also play something like c4
and their position is very very you know
solid
because all the pawns are protected they
just have more space this bishop is kind
of awkward
this bishop can come to c3 you know and
put pressure on the diagonal this knight
can come to d4 and f5
um but essentially
uh here yes here
knight f6 is a move knight f6 attacking
the pawn on
d5 and if for example they play c4
to just defend it now you can take take
and you see that f7 is not
it's not unprotected right so you
actually have time to make a move for
your own
as black and you can play something like
playing b6 and you're completely fine
so that's one thing that i wanted to
mention
and um it's just kind of has to do with
like how precise this is sometimes
because this is equal and now this
taking accidentally a little too fast um
with takes and 95 and bishop to b5
now this is plus one between plus one
actually 0.8 more or less and plus one
for
for white just simply because they have
more
more um initiative than before
so you know i hope this shows you like
how you have to be so careful with the
sicilians sometimes
and look to f8
was played rook to e1 bishop to f6
knight to d4 knight to g4 was played
and now really quickly i want to ask you
guys um
what do you think is the best move in
this position to proceed with your
with your initiative and attack
also there are some threats of bishop to
e5 so you have to be careful about that
anyone has any clues
gary played a very interesting move in
the game however what do you think is
the best way to continue
do we play h3 i guess h3 is a
possibility
i mean i think bishop e5 can be very
annoying
yes
night of three maybe maybe
out of three there could be this
annoying queen b6 though
i think
like if knight f3 there could be some of
this i don't know
looks a bit sketchy
knight to f5 yeah actually knight to f5
is the best move in the position
very interesting knight knight f5 right
that's how we shall say it knife f5 and
of course the idea is that a bishop
takes wind takes
knight to e5 now king h1 and you have
the bishop player right so like b6
bishop c3
and you even possibly have ideas of
takes in bishop d3 but
why do that when you just kind of enjoy
the bishop fair
so 92.5 was really interesting um
however the move that was played in the
game
uh was knight to e6
and i would say that both of them are
kind of i would say that kind of them
are very
you know solid for black black is the
one kind of
um uh no sorry both of them are solid
for
for white although knight f5 is slightly
better than knight to e6 but both of
them are
very very strong and of course the main
idea is that we're going to
try and coat up the bishop from g4 right
so after that pawn takes happened queen
takes
e5 when g3
unfortunately most of white's a vintage
kind of just went away
and the bishop to d7 queen to b3
queen to b6 which should be six uh
queen c7 bishop d3 rookie 8 and
overall you know i would say that the
the middle game
from now on was just mainly
uneventful bishop takes not really
possible
because of queen c5 right so that's one
thing there are a lot of tricks
um so
queen to a3 happened to cover um
c5 queen to b8
what happens if bishop takes now have
you guys been paying attention
what happens now to white
yeah 27 very good very good you guys are
good
so bishop to d4 was played
bishop back and
they just kind of went around a couple
of moves uh
and then they had this really incredible
bishop takes
just crazy um i mean of course you know
they didn't um
accidentally stumble upon this of course
but as we know phonetics is terribly
losing because of this
and there are ideas of queen h7 there's
this rook in the game
there's queen g6 also
um everything is kind of hanging and the
bishop here takes takes
queen g6 is really strong
so visual takes h6 you cannot take it
back but if you think about it
like how much does it accomplish because
you don't have to
you don't have to take back on h6 you're
not forced to do that
and that's kind of something that black
kept in mind
and they played b takes a4 and the thing
is that now
uh things are a little awkward because
the screen cannot get to g5
i would love to but there is a bishop on
e7 that is preventing that
and um so after it takes bishop d5 was
played
and now bishop to h3 takes takes
takes when a7
takes and
this end game was just eventually drawn
so i mean i can show you the remaining
moves
so after queen takes through k8 bring
back
here and i would say that the main thing
in this in this end games is don't allow
your opponent to get too much counter
play
uh because of your slightly weak king so
essentially if you have a weaker king in
this type of positions
um try to you know
be mindful of that because there are
still
uh heavy pieces on the board and this is
you know one of those cases where the
kings are a little weak
and after route 282
queen went back if one here
uh there's this queen g6 idea
with check and coming back so like if
okay six
something like this
so when b7 was played
c4 rook a83
and it was just
so um i don't know i thought it was very
interesting
this this variations and um i think
you know it kind of helps for general
neither for understanding
i don't think we'll have time but i also
prepared some stuff with bishop g5
uh however i have kind of talked about
this move before
on lectures especially this
line with queen v6 personally i really
like h6
here and then queen b6
because uh if you were following the
uh i think this was a
napoleon chi against geary game if you
are following their games
you can see that f4 queen b6 knight b3
was playing
and very interesting variation
um but if you play h6
here here this is not an option anymore
knight two b3 do you guys know why
let me flip the point
do you guys know why
i'm not going to show you how how to
defeat my opening
that would be kind of silly
also how can you ensure that this is my
opening
i don't know what the nope and no are
referring to
but okay so going to
point to e3 yes and the idea is that
you're giving a check
and f4 is hanging because before the
bishop was on g5 right so you have
nothing to worry about
but here you do have a lot of stuff to
worry about because the upward pawn is
kind of hanging
so um yeah
just saying that's one thing but in this
queen b6 line
um i don't know if you guys uh were here
when i was doing a lecture on this
perhaps a month or two ago um but i was
talking about these lines with 22 which
are
very you know sharp of course and queen
takes should be one
um we even looked at i think we looked
at f
no uh sorry queen here we looked at
bishop e2 right bishop b2 knight c6
which we do knight c6 takes takes
this and
we're looking at this right
um
how do you guys how would you guys play
here if you wear white pieces
do i have any ideas no okay
do you guys remember if you were here
and you don't remember
shame on you if you're new
well there's nothing i can do about that
um yeah
okay i can go back to the variation
right now to show you about 92 the
inconvenience about that is that d4 is
hanging but i'm gonna
play it out on the board for you
you can't remember shame on you
just kidding um i mean especially if you
don't know don't play the opening can be
tough to remember
but here um e6 is a very strong move
we're looking at the
um caruana versus mvl game from tata
still this year
so
this move is really strong really really
strong so
um yeah
the idea of course is that if bishop
takes
then f5 you know like castle f5 through
g1 like the file is going to be open
and if they take with pawn which is
really ugly there are still ideas of f5
and f6 if you don't open up everything
so even some of this too
so in general it's just kind of like a
really sharp variation for
for black but we were talking about this
a little while ago
so yeah
and this didn't happen in these games uh
in fact f5 is what was played and then
knight c6 of course
takes i think people take on e6 with the
bishop sometimes i think taken with the
phone makes a lot of sense
and then takes takes bishop b2 bishop e7
and apparently after e5 takes takes
takes
bishop h5 g6 knight e4
very scary stuff castle
castle bishop g7 there's not much to
worry about
so if you want you can take a further
look into this into these games and
um watch the commentary from the from
the tournaments
you know um like whatever run in the
tournament and
i think if you go to chess moment you
just kind of look through the games
you'll see
uh a ton of sicilians and specifically a
ton of neither so if this is your
um area you can go check it out because
the best people in the world are playing
it so
um you know might as well learn from
them
so and you know they already put so many
hours into their analysis
so we might as well you know grab a
chunk of that work that they already
did